present Trump true story took to Twitter
to criticize modern air travel yes not
making this up this was his tweet
airplanes are becoming far too complex
to fly pilots are no longer needed but
rather computer scientists from MIT I
don't know about you but I don't want
Albert on it's time to be my pilot yes
that's the big problem with planes these
days yes advanced technology pilots are
too smart yeah too smart yeah too much
technology
well no planes went down in the 1920s
that's for sure packwood they were
basically big kites let's go back to
that well today believe it or not Trump
doubled down and he's relaunching one of
his old businesses to try and save the
day he announced it with a brand new ad
here it is
airplanes who even knows how to use them
anymore I mean except for a fancy
scientist they become so complicated
some experts believe ant the buttons are
fake
can you believe that that's why the time
is now to relaunch the fantastic totally
save trump Airlines bike lanes are very
simple each cockpit is stripped down to
just do anything
we don't need Albert Einstein to fly our
planes in fact most of our pilots have
IQs in the mid-50s
airlines fly the unbelievable